hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are gonna talk about a
special thing today fandoms oh good and
the negative effects that can happen
with it toxicity just our thoughts and
opinions on this at our patreon one of
our top reward tiers is whatever video
you're requesting was definitely doing
put up on the youtubes it's usually a
reaction and today is a rare case where
a person named Michael be Michael Boone
has a channel himself on me one media
check it out awesome reactions over
there and reviews as well and he
specifically asked us to touch on this
topic here and it's something that we
don't really like we might talk about
every once in a while usually make a lot
of sarcastic comments about or whatever
but it's not something that we have
liked ever do dedicated videos on or
whatever and I've seen like video essays
about this subject and I've seen people
complain on the internet on the internet
about stuff I've heard a lot of
different opinions about fandom in
general and interesting discussion
especially after doing YouTube for
several years now and dealing with many
a fandom communities especially after
you have opinions about it
yeah deep into the belly of the fandom
beast yeah engaging with it on a daily
weekly basis and we decided to this
podcast format and riff format style for
this so you know we don't have notes for
this I was originally planning on making
notes and I kind of just said to myself
before making notes no I'm too tired and
lazy now work that's too much I don't
want to prep now I was like I feel like
I can just come from the heart on this
one this this is to me I'm I not well
versed I'm like that's not true I've had
to deal with so many so many kinds of
fandom putting my opinions out there and
and you know dealing with all kinds of
toxicity and I just were going into this
I'll say I know I go on movie fights
I've been on there five times in the
past year now right for six I don't know
matter so I go a movie fights and before
I go into any of my opinions on any of
these things even though I love going on
that show even though I tend to do a
pretty good job when I'm on that show in
real life I look I suck at fighting
actually I think I do because I don't
like it I generally don't I don't like
fighting with you like fighting with my
girlfriend I don't like fighting with my
brother these are the main people I
discussed movies with off-camera and in
general if I don't like going to a press
screening and knowing that there's gonna
be people who probably have a different
opinion cuz I'm just not if I don't
believe in trying to tell people how
they feel or think about something is
wrong and I know how to respectfully
disagree I feel like that movie fights
championship one that I have a damn
morals a good example all right people I
think I really like that because we were
obviously not nasty towards each other
even though we're movie fighting there's
obvious that we respectfully disagree at
the end of the day and plus you know you
kind of energy that is expected I don't
like dealing with social media
oh I dealing with comments like I don't
generally so as much as I love green
ghoul movie fights and doing a good job
on there I generally have an issue with
the way how some elements offend
community can be and I'm not he I don't
want to break down there's all you know
big fandoms like there's the Rick and
Morty one there's the BTS one there's a
wide variety of Star Wars and I'm not
here to specifically nitpick any of
those fandoms because they all have they
all have similar threads in the way they
all form yeah in every anything that can
gather a fanbase there will be annoying
evangelistic fans who you know just cram
that down your throat all the time it's
it just happens you know it's been
happening with things forever
it's the way it's the religion I've
heard it that the most the most
modern-day fan
would have to be with actually like
Sherlock Holmes because that's sort of
like late 1800s and then that eventually
that started the birth of like
modern-day fandom in a way which
eventually led into sci-fi territory so
that was like the proto fandom yeah yeah
yeah like people were just like where
people started like having meetings and
talking about it and creating things of
building upon it interested fanfiction I
think so yeah I'm pretty sure that's
what I heard where I'm not here to like
give a whole history through what is
fandom how do you define have people
been interested in things together
yeah it's there's something specific
like consider fandom and then there's
but I feel like with almost anything if
there's a fan base there's a fandom for
it
that's what fandom is yeah it's a bunch
of people who share a common interest to
a certain
yeah and I think personally there's
there's a lot of beautiful things about
a fandom community and I feel like
overall there's probably more good than
bad and the common belief that I hear
with people who speak out against
toxicity of fandom communities is that
that negative voice is really the
minority and they're just very loud you
know that's the common thing I don't
know if that's true yeah feeling a lot
of Star Wars fans don't like the debate
but I think there is an element of truth
to that I mean we've often talked about
like Yelp is I feel like the people more
compelled to go voice their opinion or
the people who have your negative
opinion versus it's easier to take a
positive opinion and go about your day
while I feel like oh there's people who
are very I feel like there's a lot of
love in this world I also feel like a
lot of those same people and myself
included at times can be quite drawn to
negativity not that I'm a negative
person but every once in a while if I
see a headline about something negative
ooh
whether it be people are upset about
this or what did Trump do wrong today
like there's that element in my mind
that is like I want to know
I want to read about this hmm I think
the issue that occurs with with a fandom
toxicity is specifically what that means
is I've heard a thing about
communication before that says don't
attack the person attack the problem and
admittedly I can sometimes be at fault
for that work lately the past couple
years I am unintentionally attacking the
person without realizing I'm attacking
the person when I should just stay
focused on the problems to them
sometimes when I'm attacking the problem
like oh should have been attacking the
person you dial it back and realize no
I'm not you might lose the problem to
make yeah the person to make the problem
worse so I feel like the issue is
actually within communication about
disagreements because we all have our
own opinions holder we all have our own
values we all have we're and we're all
passionate that's the whole thing that
that stems with fandom is a is a passion
for whatever it is that's the beautiful
thing about it like it's even if we
don't consider ourselves a creative type
that creative side in us is drawn to
whatever this creative thing is because
that is a that is calling into our
creative intuitions that's calling into
our passionate things whether it be for
BTS kpop or supernatural the television
show you know it's all factoring in to
this something that's resonant and I
think the main issue is literally how we
attack people and not the issue we have
with what's been done for example I
don't like the movie glass you know
mm-hm there's obviously been offended
around glass that whole universe shall
on others and it's not be one of motors
it might not be one of the most notable
fandoms but there is a fandom around it
bottom line I had a moment with that
movie where I was like [ __ ] you movie
but you will now and I even I've even
said that I feel like a lot of
expectations were very much set because
of things M night Shyamalan has said but
I have never gone out of my way to
attack M night Shyamalan I have never
been like screw you stop making movies
you've lost it you yeah I never I've
attacked the movie I've attacked the
problems I've had with the movie but
I've never attacked M night Shyamalan as
a human being or as a person and I
really feel like that's the main problem
that we have with the toxicity element
that occurs when we hate something in a
movie or a show or whatever when you
don't like Kelly Marie trans character
in the last Jedi
so you attack her on social media when
that's really undeserved that's not fair
she does like yes why he called for in
it and it's crossing over into a
completely other conversation mm-hmm
which which yeah is ultimately what
vexes me I feel like the the Internet
has done a fascinating thing because
before that I mean we had phones and
stuff but just like your range of
socialization was just much smaller and
much more confined to reality real world
whereas now you can kind of see and hear
everything and and especially online
there is a lot of incentive to be
hyperbolic and to have fun with the way
that you write which is not in and of
itself a bad thing but I do think that
the big thing we're learning about right
now is how we all communicate to each
other in Mass because more so than ever
before we have this capability to
communicate to anybody we want kind of
and I think that's teaching us things
about yeah that the separation between
this has been in everybody's mouth
lately but like art and artists and
things like that and and separation of
our feelings towards something versus
you know how we interact with everybody
in regard to those feelings and the
problem for me is I see like phantoms
are built on passion which is beautiful
and problematic because if anybody
attacks something that you're passionate
about it's natural to get defensive yeah
and not just to take it personal yeah
exactly exactly in fact I had a brief
exchange just yesterday on Facebook with
somebody who hit us up I read it yeah
this morning and I was like funny thing
we're talking about this today yes and I
don't know what it is about that guy
like four so this guy specifically just
feels this need to keep messaging us
yeah and it's been
and it's like leave us yeah and I'm not
I I don't stable phone a lot of the day
just because it helps me focus to not be
near the phone but for some reason this
guy's messages always come in when I'm
like right there and for some reason he
begins them in a way where I'm like I I
have to read this for some reason and
and yeah and he presented an argument
that was basically like you guys are
just haters and you want to see such and
such a property taken down and destroyed
you're idiots and [ __ ] you guys and and
you know all you love is this and so I
responded I was like actually here are
some facts about what we do and here's
my opinion in my point of view and then
I came back and was like it's not your
opinion you're just a hater and you hate
stuff and so it created this fascinating
moment where I was like okay I can see
very clearly that this has nothing to do
with me other than hearing my opinion or
our opinions cause this guy to react but
this is clearly about somebody who feels
you know hurt in the same capacity
because that's what it really does seem
to be about and I feel like that's what
we're all learning about right now is
that yeah passion around things when
people disagree with you it does
sometimes hurt which is a weird thing
because it's not like it's you it's not
like it's even like a physical part of
you it's something that you're attached
to that you care about but yeah I don't
know the way people attack each other
over the things that they're passionate
about has gotten kind of out of control
because I feel like people have lost the
just scale of everything it's like if
it's a movie there's no reason we should
behave half the ways in which we do if
people are upset about Star Wars that's
fine you can totally it comes back to
what you said you can hate glass but
there's absolutely no reason to go do
tell M night Shyamalan to kill himself
because it's just a piece of art like
Ryan Jones or Ryan Joe Kelly Marie Tran
or will Poulter just recently a cast of
the Ghostbusters reboot and that's the
big whipping post for me personally
because Ghostbusters finally broke us
draw for me where that that whole
situation happened and I like the
original Ghostbusters I watched it a ton
growing up and up until that point I was
like yeah Ghostbusters great it's
classic blah blah blah I'm excited that
there will be more and when that whole
thing happened it just made everything
so ugly on both sides because then
everybody lost their sense and I feel
like with these passions that are so
strong you know it's like the art we
love fills us up in a lot of ways but
it's also really easy to fly off a
handle I mean it seems like there's a we
have a terrible communication problem
and dissin how to disagree and we have a
terrible way of of listening where we do
selective listening for example it's
like if you some there's certain see I
don't think it was problem with fandoms
I think the promised certain fans that's
the issue it's it's the kinds of fans if
if they love something and you only kind
of like it that interprets to them as
you must lean everybody I said certain
fans if you if they love something and
you kind of only like it that interprets
to them as you hate it yeah and if you
if they if they hate something and you
kind of like it
it can interpret to you love it yeah and
sometimes it's just in the middle and
that's a okay like I was pretty nervous
about putting out my opinion on Aquaman
because I was just smack dab in the
middle about that movie and I didn't
hate it by any stretch nor did I love it
so I'm like I just gotta find a way to
articulate this and surprisingly there
are some hate comments you know I'm sure
whoever that annoying ass dude who keeps
message no surprise that review and took
it took that as you hate easy when I'm
like no if you stay till the end of my
review I flat out said I want to see who
I want James wanna return I mean that do
you know well that's that conversation
yeah even in even in talking DC because
that that there could be comes this like
Rand adherence I feel like we're again
something you love so I mean it's it's
it's a choosing sides thing yeah and I'm
like it doesn't need to be that there
can be a gray I can tell you I like the
Ghostbusters reboot it's nowhere near as
good as the original
but that doesn't mean I prefer this
really like yeah this just doesn't yea
match the proportions of civilized
reality and and like that conversation
yesterday made me think cuz the guy
basically said like you hate everything
DC I went out of my way to go no
actually there's fair amount of things
we like even loved just not these couple
things and there was that point of like
well I love everything DC and so I feel
like people have trouble also being
objective and we all do it to some
degree on to everything it's a things
that we love but I feel like people have
trouble being objective sometimes and
just looking at things for what they are
like I'm all for having passion over art
but a movie at the end of the day is
just a movie there's just a minute just
a it's a it's a story it's a moment
there's like five more come out next
week exactly and so it does seem I do
wonder where that intensity level comes
from where this is so important to
people that your consideration for the
other people around you goes out the
window
yeah because I can't stand the
all-or-nothing it's like you either a
completely disagree or you either
completely agree and honestly it doesn't
matter if you disagree or agree you're
allowed to have your own opinion and
your and you could even put out your
opinion on why you disagree with that
person yeah but man I can't if how many
people have been like you didn't like
this one sub or you love this unsub
people might be personal if I was like
that at all with the amount of youtubers
that's all recommending glass this is
the most recent movie that's why I'm
talking about like I would have
unsubscribe to screen junkies news
they're like were hardcore supporters of
that movie but I wasn't like [ __ ] you
Dan and Rob like that's just their
opinion you know yeah
here's it it's it's so well of course
you know they were doing a podcast on
the car alarm has to go off you know
funny we shot it at this time to maybe
avoid some yeah okay it's going to be
leaf blowers right outside let's shoot
this time okay now now of course
someone's car alarm is going on is just
unbelievably distracting it's like doing
a stand-up show and there's like a flick
I want to know but I've heard other
comics talk about it yeah so now go
louder yeah this is gonna be viral see
that's the thing that that they always
told us in like criticism and in writing
in school it's like you don't need to
establish that this is your feeling or
that you know it's an opinion or or a
take because that's the conceit of
whatever you're writing however in
interacting just out in the world I've
come to find it like crucial to always
kind of make sure people know that what
you're trying to express is just an
opinion because I started to notice back
in the days like what would bother me
personally is just it's a semantic thing
it's a small thing but when people cast
something aside as though it does just
suck like when people I feel like maybe
people respond poorly to the lack of
acknowledgement in the subjectivity of
art because when people get hyperbolic
and they get passionate it's easy to
just trash a movie and be like this is
hot garbage and and that makes people
kind of upset and I and I get where that
particular thing comes from which is why
at least in my response to this all I'm
always like I try to make it clear that
this is just how I took it this was my
experience and you are free to have your
own different experience like I get
bummed out too when you know like last
year half the albums I was most
anticipating got middling to negative
reviews from the music critics I follow
doesn't mean I didn't get my own
enjoyment out of those albums and at the
time I was like oh I wish they like this
but to me that's about the extent is I
wish we agreed on this that's a decent
point you know you know I've I've never
actually met someone
who
is who's actually pursuing like
consistently pursuing not just I want to
be a writer or I want to be an actor I
want to make films I want to make comics
not someone who just says that I've
never met someone who actually is who
has made it is making it or is pursuing
it who has this kind of behavior no you
know what I mean
no you got to be able to play with other
see so it makes me wonder because I
honestly don't know who these people are
that have such as strong it's like
they're up there love for a thing has
made it part of their identity in who
they are so they start feeling
personally attacked when you disagree in
any capacity for it that it makes me
wonder if if they were active artists in
their own endeavors with this thing
bother them as much you know yeah
because I've never personally honestly I
might have met people who do that [ __ ]
online and I just had no idea that they
do that you know a lot of times people
hide that's that's the thing is people
that some of those hateful comments
don't even have a profile photo we can
yeah yeah I think that anonymity mask
and feel free and comfortable to say and
do a lot of things you wouldn't normally
and that's also very telling and I feel
like that's for everybody who does it to
realize about themselves and to figure
out I guess cuz yeah I don't know at the
end of the day they're just been so many
situations and and I go always go back
to Ghost Busters because yeah that
crossed the line of this is wholly
unreasonable now like that we are being
terrible to each other and nobody's
opinion is helping any of that it's like
yeah whether or not you think this is a
good idea or a bad idea everyone's
behaving ugly and and that's the toxic
power that scares me kind of because you
can watch everybody lose their sense
really fast yeah well I guess at the
very top it goes right back to you it's
totally okay to disagree it's totally
okay to voice that disagreement but it's
a whole thing to attack people that's
why man why main issue
with the with the specific negativity of
fandom is the attacking of another human
being how many people have had suicide
attempts because of being attacked on
social media or had to close ourselves
off from life because of the it's like
guys this isn't [ __ ] life or death
man it's it's a movie it's a song it's
music it's a comic book this is art and
we're all out of have our opinions but
quit attacking the the fact that this
artist actually mates these people have
made something it's and the the insult
it's like with the reboots of like
Ghostbusters I first personally I don't
have that feeling for Ghostbusters that
other people apparently have like it's a
sacred text of some kind of see but I
okay some people do have that feeling
with it that it's a sacred text to the
degree of like how they feel about star
war like some people feel about star
wars you know I might not be able to see
it but hey there are people who do and
I'm gonna respect that I don't care how
much you love it that is no right to
attack individuals that inspires and
then that makes me go you know what it's
not a sacred yeah exactly like then I
find myself [ __ ] attacking that
because I'm like well co-sponsoring that
sounds a damn comedy movie right yeah
it's like we could all agree on certain
aspect of it but now I'm losing sight of
respecting the fact that you love this
so much and there's a fandom for it
because of just how malicious you're
being to other to individual people out
there but then that makes you wonder is
there a responsibility to go and check
the the view that this is a sacred thing
ya know is it
and also I I think a lot of this time
with the fandom toxicity that can occur
is the like like I said a lot of my [ __ ]
just boils on to a few things selective
hearing
I know there are be people whoever
happens to listen to this who are gonna
pick and choose what they want to hear
about what we're saying you know they're
not gonna hear the whole thing they're
gonna be picking pick this hone in on
that
take this hone in on that you know
instead of going well actually he made
counter op you know the counterpoint do
that and that's a scary thing just about
living in the now because it's really
hard to spit out a big picture that
isn't microsite yeah do you know like I
mean it's it's a no it's like with the
comments that we see on YouTube
sometimes we could do a whole review a
trailer reaction review it or a movie
review say like 99 things and then out
of say a hundred things get 99 of them
right
for whoever listened yeah and then one
part of one thing all the comments yeah
it's sad it's really sad it said it
instead of just like really listening to
it I think a lot of times we have we we
determine like as much as I the reason I
specifically singled out with M night
Shyamalan putting expectations for that
was because I really did believe he put
out the expectations but I feel like a
lot of the time expectation is just our
own perspective that we have sort of
created yeah you know and as an argument
for that for what I did with glass too
but a lot of times it's this idea of of
expectation and not fulfilling what that
individual specifically expected so I'm
going to attack the person who created
this thing yeah that for some reason
they feel like has ruined their
childhood or something like that people
are like the Ghostbusters reboot ruined
my childhood like I know there's gonna
people who listen to this ago all we
talked about what Ghostbusters a glass
oh yeah I'm like okay but the consistent
examples to break something down more
yeah honestly hearing about the fandom
of Rick and Morty has made me not want
to get involved in Rick and Morty dude
the creators of the show were like for
the love of God don't be terrible to
McDonald's workers over this isn't even
our thing like yes it was on our show
but like don't be terrible to people in
real life just for our cartoon thing
yeah like and it and it's just
interesting that this is such a chronic
issue now because I feel like there's a
lot of people on a sofa there's a lot
people the lack of identity of people
with a lack of purpose there's that and
they find their calling
in this there's as that's why I brought
it that's why I brought that point of
people who I feel like who are pursuing
those are people it's either really
going after what they have defined as
their purpose in life and I feel like
the people without purpose have made is
that we all have a need for identity we
all have a need for purpose we all have
a need for significance we all have
these human needs and somehow people
have found their needs through this yeah
yeah and and and you know there's also
just affection is just as things are
special to us things are you know we
hold dear and we give these values to
it's like when you start a YouTube
channel
once it starts growing once you're in
growing phase like oh it's growing
you met with a lot of love I see mmm
when you start like remember this
channel was started off growing I
remember like [ __ ] discovering the
raid and then did the vampire movie I
forget what it's called but the bad part
when suddenly I was like the first day
it was like 500 subscribers in a day I
was like and there's like nothing but
love and love and love vampire yeah and
then and then after a while oh now
there's hate and that's just the thing
when anything grows it is like something
just hate comes out of it it's and
that's to be expected but yeah my bait
my main problem is attacking people the
selective hearing and lack of
open-mindedness you know yeah like
that's the thing yeah well we live in a
society that reinforces the idea that
you're supposed to have one conclusion
and it shouldn't change you know if
you're a youtuber who's doing a review
saying if you liked this movie you're
[ __ ] stupid then that person should
be attacked you set yourself up to be
attacked at that point but if they're
not going after the ones who like it why
I just it's it's it is mind-boggling and
it's funny how this this conversation of
toxicity and phantom has become such a
topic in and of itself just how dark it
is in with social media has broad
well and yeah there cuz there's that too
I mean I feel like now we live in this
time where everything is on demand and
everything is bite-sized and everything
is curated into a feed with an algorithm
to sculpt what it looks like to you and
so like I feel like people's minds now
more than ever are just a bit noisier
and more fractured and like for me the I
already struggle with the perception of
time but as technology has gotten better
and the push in culture has been towards
quick and easy so much time feels all
the more fragmented and and and yeah I
feel like that further reinforces this
knee-jerk thing that happens when people
like check into an opinion for a couple
minutes hear one thing and then fly off
the hair without waiting to hear the
rest of it because I feel like just the
the bubble we live in now incentivizes
you to do that because everything wants
your attention attention is like the
main commodity now and yeah it's intense
in it in a way that it shouldn't be cuz
we're all just logging online to talk to
each other and and you know congregate
over the stuff we like and for some
reason that has become like pressured
and I feel like it also cuts the other
way too it's I feel like toxic fandom
isn't just ugly I feel like we can lose
ourselves by being so into something or
so hyped about stuff that we kind of can
lose just a clear or minded view on it
you know as well and so yeah I don't
know I I wonder where the I feel like
this comes from a multitude of places
partly as issues about identity or just
people who maybe feel very alone and
have these you know it's like arts
especially films move us they bring us
emotional responses and they're
populated by people you know so they are
a very human experience in a way and so
I I get how for somebody who maybe that
is one of the bedrocks of their life how
that could route so intensely to the
point that if they hear boo about it
they're going to attack and defend like
I get it I just yeah I feel like we need
to all kind of I feel like what social
media and then the future has is
teaching us right now is the ways in
which we all haven't grown up and the
ways
in which we need to kind of force
ourselves to come to a certain middle
ground about things yeah kind of see a
soberly to a degree because it's like
social media and phones and everything
they take communication and interaction
and make it a game and so I feel like
we're all kind of warped right now and
that only makes this conversation worse
it's like there was toxic fandom before
this I was just more isolated and now
you can kind of spray it everywhere and
and it's a it's a learning experience
that I think we're all kind of figuring
out yeah well yeah dislike this video
and leave a hate comment and we won't
read any of it or if you made it to the
end and you listen to everything I don't
know go hug somebody yeah go find
somebody you disagree with and reassure
them that you still like them as a
person mm-hmm you know that's why I like
our patrons because there are many
people who disagree with me about
Bohemian Rhapsody and daredevil season 3
but none of them attacked me as an
individual yeah cuz odds are we're just
not all gonna like all the same sexual
activity of art people yes what it is
and what and there's even a subjectivity
in what we call art yeah but there's an
art to everything even a Ghostbusters
reboot yeah I mean my my main thing is I
try to make it very clear when I speak
now that this is just my experience of
the thing and this is my opinion about
it because I think ultimately that is
the very simple linchpin is people throw
out hot takes and opinions as though
they are fact which immediately
especially rioting causes everybody to
walk by and go hey wait a minute you
know and then a did what could have been
a discussion turns into it battle fair
you know all right guys well you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us out
patreon
thank you Michael B for requesting this
interesting to get our opinion out there
about it the few hundred people are
listening to this thanks for listening
along go check on Michael B's Channel
Omni won media he's also a fan
so gentleman who has had long long
conversations with me and still
continues to this day
he's a very supportive humble human
being and he will be a huge internet
personality one of these days
much love be safe and be kind to
everyone out there will ya